hey guys happy check Tuesday today is
going to be a two-part episode where I
show you the vlogging camera that I've
been using for the past couple of months
and show you this new fun project from
Canon it's called project imagination
the trailer where you guys use their
online video editing tool to create a
trailer which potentially could be then
turned into a short film by Ron Howard
and Josh Hutcherson which is kind of
pretty freakin awesome
I made a trailer from what I went to
Paris so if you guys haven't seen that
yet check it out I'll put a link in the
description also a link to get this
camera and also a link to check out the
project imagination trailer creators so
let's get this video started there's
there's gonna be a lot of content so get
yourself some snacks have a seat prepare
yourself for another fantastic tech
Tuesday so first up we're gonna talk
about the canon g7x here it is this
thing is absolutely it just it's amazing
I've kind of kept it a secret because
I've liked it so much I was like I don't
want to share my secrets with everyone
Here I am I'm talking about it because
so many of you guys have been asking
about the camera that I've been using
and this isn't g7x one of the things
that you guys are also gonna notice is
it is priced a little bit higher than
most of the point in shoots that I've
covered here ever I'm not gonna lie it's
worth it I've went through so many
cameras to try to find the perfect
vlogging camera and they've pretty much
nailed it so the highlights that I like
about this camera is it has a bigger
sensor so it lets in a lot more light
the image stabilization in video and
taking photos it's pretty impressive
also the flip screen and some of the
previous vlogging cameras that have
covered you'll know that I always wanted
that just to go all the way up and this
one does just that it's also a
touchscreen so you're able to touch to
focus it's also got this little circular
ring right here which you can set to do
pretty much whatever you want it to do I
have mine currently set to zoom it has a
lot of customization and different
shooting modes photos for videos it will
also shoot 1080 60 frames a second so
you guys can shoot some really fun
slow-mo videos one of my highlights of
this camera and I definitely recommend
if this isn't the camera that you're
going to get make sure any of your
cameras that you do get from Canon have
the Wi-Fi enabled because it has made
such a huge difference for me I actually
no longer take photos on my iPhone I
take them all on here you just press
this little button right here and this
will send it into its Wi-Fi mode
essentially this camera creates its own
little Wi-Fi hotspot you can connect
your phone to the Wi-Fi download the
Canon app that's kind of great so right
now you can see all of the
that I took last night at a concert and
I just save those right onto my phone
and I can post on Instagram share it on
Twitter posted on Facebook basically do
whatever I want to do with them it's
also pretty cool because you could
import the video that you take from here
so sometimes when I'm traveling and I
just want to get a quick vlog edited I
will edit it right here on my phone so
I'll show you the remote shooting option
so I'm gonna control this directly from
the phone and you can see what my camera
sees I mean pretty much the coolest
thing ever you guys can actually shoot
RAW photos on here so for some of you
higher-end photographers that's probably
something that you might be into if you
want to go back in and edit and have
kind of that full resolution image I
could go on all day about this camera
another thing I love is the depth of
field you're able to get really precise
depth of field so some of you guys might
not even know what that means but when
the background is blurry and you're in
focus or your subject is in focus that's
the depth of field and this camera has
an amazing depth of field so some of
those photos that you might see me take
you like well your iPhone takes great
photos I did not take them with my
iPhone a lot of times too I'll be
shooting in low-light situations and
this camera gets the job done like I
cannot say enough good things about this
camera and I'm I might be in love with
it I hope that you love me too
so that's a g7x if you guys want more
information there's links in the
description they actually currently have
a $50 instant rebate so if you're
looking to get this camera I would get
it while they've got the discount now
it's time to move on to the canon
project imagination trailer creator go
alright welcome to my desk I'm going to
show you guys the canon project
imagination trailer creator and it's
super simple it's pretty much an online
video editing tools to upload your clips
and my favorite part they have these vo
clips so if you guys watch my trailer
you can have like a professional vo
person basically narrate your trailer
let's get started shall we alright
super easy create your trailer the
contest ends April 29th in a world in a
town in the future so a few different
ways you can create your trailer you can
either make one where they edit it for
you kind of mashing all your clips
together or you can use their editing
tool here which is what I did pretty
much give you all of the tools possible
you got music
you've got titles you can have it
oh here are some of my clips that I've
uploaded to create my trailer you just
take your clips you could drop them in
here are some photos oh my friends oh
look at that photo not supposed to be
there Marsh stuff here's my timeline
oops I just moved something there is an
undo here's the undo so you could upload
any kind of media you want you can
actually even connect your Instagram and
your Facebook and your Flickr to get any
of the footage or photos from wherever
you might actually have it or you can
upload it directly from your computer
once it's uploaded it'll be here in all
of your media so here's where all of
your music is you can choose from
various music options such as
action-adventure or comedy here's the
voice overs which is my favorite part in
a house rated PG you can just drag and
drop those into your timeline if you
guys have ever used any video editing
software it's very similar to any other
editing suite that you've probably
already used you've got your text
you can set different themes can also
choose a genre so it'll already choose
to the music or text that you would
already want there's also a storyboard
mode and you guys have never edited
before this might be a good place to
start because it'll kind of give you a
little bit easier of a timeline to work
with when you're done just hit finalize
which is right here that'll render all
of your Clips together and upload it for
Canon to review to make sure it's okay
to be submitted into the contest I'm so
excited about doing this project because
I have been such a big Canon fan pretty
much forever
it's the cameras that I use for
everything and I'm just so excited to be
able to share this with you guys and I
hope you enjoyed the review let me know
what cameras you guys use and let me
know if there's any features that you
guys think is a must-have thing in
vlogging cameras leave them in the
comments below just maybe they'll put it
in the next camera I love you guys
thanks for watching don't forget to like
I'll see you soon if you guys make a
trailer be sure to send it to me because
I can't wait to watch them
bye-bye